now I'm part in part one right you've
got that result then they give you the
area function for x times the square
root of sixty-four build on the one okay
now I was astonished and this happened
multiple times but this is the first
time it happened which is my mentioning
now I was astonished by how many people
then went to integrate and appeal to
some kind of treat substitution okay now
as far as I know I'll just double check
this I don't think he had had to do a
trick solution for any of the questions
okay and almost invariably made you're
working out two or three times longer
did it mean you got the wrong answer
though sometimes you did okay but more
importantly it just made it long pages
and pages you could handle of all
algebraically okay the clue for you is
that you can see you know that X hat the
front that's part of the derivative of
the inside function right that's part of
the derivative of 64 minus X minus one
on one okay so therefore you can treat
it as reverse chain rule no tree
required okay I'll quickly tell you part
a part 12 marks the first respectively
in the square some of you skipped over
there which is a bit dangerous when
you've got to show a question the second
mark was for putting together the
dimensions right so you need to do a
line like this
okay now some of you skip straight to
forex it's a show a question that result
is given to you know Mark are either
here or in HSC will pay anything for
writing down something that the question
has provided for you this is worthless
okay you must show how you got it now
see this statement even though like
algebraically there's a trivial
difference right but in terms of meaning
why is that a significant line up there
what do those two things represent now a
very good they represent the dimensions
horizontal and vertical dimensions of
the cylindrical shell wants you unwrap
it right represent dimensions they
represent meaning okay good throwing
away marks by golly greediness part 24
marks okay um so the way i did was i did
it by some petition right you can just
say let u equal this and it falls out
easily enough if you did it by a
shifting sort of method or trigonometric
where otherwise much that was the first
mark second mark was for rearranging
that integral into an appropriate form
okay now i think how look at this line
with me okay at some point you get to
here um this is if you follow my
substitution or you have something
equivalent okay now i can understand i
guess this is my I'll forgive you moment
okay I understand why some of you looked
at this and you appeal to treat cuz
you're like whatever I supposed to do
with this this is no standard for what's
it going to look like ok now it's not a
standard form but it is the sum of two
integrals which are close enough to stay
24 watch okay if I break this apart okay
take my for here Big Rapids
negative 8 48 of this guy and then
another integral negative 8 to 80 this
coming ok now I wonder if it's a little
clearer for you ok one of them is an
obvious standard form which one the
second one because what kind of shape is
this once you take the tape out the
front that's a semicircle so you don't
need to know anything about integration
to work out the area of a semicircle so
he's fine now this one is a little more
involved i'll admit you could go through
an internet so hope you don't need to
you don't need to have a look at it what
kind of function is this it has some
symmetry doesn't it that's some symmetry
in fact if i look at this probably see
that you square that in terms of sine
doesn't matter then turns it's you right
this is an odd function in here this is
an odd function and when you integrate
an odd function on equal sides of the
axis you got negative part you've got
positive part this part is present ok
see you got a semicircle you got 0 5 out
of cups all right make sense so when I
say number one on a substitution like
this including your boundaries good
number two was it doing something with
it and you might have done trick madam
trick in order to put into a full that's
integral ok when you can get to there
there's your shaker mark third mark
obviously you got evaluate these things
so I think you get that zero what's this
is this semicircle right is it in at the
front a semicircle me that's half pi
what's all it's the radius of eight
squared so there's another market third
one and then your final
this for evaluating signifying they go